here at least one person is infirm
charge and in contrast to the chaos of
Hong Kong Chinese President Xi Jinping
wanted to highlight order and tradition
[Music]
she stood at the same rostrum where
Chairman Mao declared the founding of
the People's Republic of China seventy
years ago today he ditched his Western
business way up for a male suit and even
sounded like the great helmsman himself
sure today a socialist China is standing
proudly in the world's East and no force
can change the position of our great
motherland China has plenty of its own
force of course and was keen for the
world to know it she inspected the
troops before him hello comrades he said
hello chairman they shouted back for all
that emphasis on history these weapons
are high-tech one of Xi's key policies
has been modernizing the country's armed
forces these are China's latest
intercontinental ballistic missiles
capable of carrying nuclear warheads
incapable to of reaching the United
States Sony they've never been shown to
the world before the unrest in Hong Kong
is the biggest challenge to communist
rule in a long while this float
represented the territory as its
embattled chief executive Carrie Lam
herself watched on
as news broke of the Hong Kong shooting
the Chinese leadership sat down to a
massive evening gala and Tamerlan Square
they were never themselves going to
interrupt these meticulously planned and
symbolically important celebrations the
pyrotechnics here are state sanctioned
the only ones allowed in Beijing today
was proof of the party's tight control
of mainland China Hong Kong shows its
limits Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing